con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de las alzas en los
precios de los combustibles como
consecuencia de la guerra en ucrania que
ha generado protestas alrededor de todo
el mundo en específico en nuestra región
nos acompaña claro que sí en nuestro
estudio daniel hablando nuestra
periodista de economía con quien más
vamos a hablar si no es contigo danny y
también nos acompaña a julio césar vera
díaz el ex presidente la fundación
ciudad energy especialista en las áreas
de operaciones regulación
comercialización distribución
actividades relacionadas con los
sectores de transporte de más
hidrocarburos combustibles líquidos y
biocombustibles gracias julio césar por
también estar con nosotros en directo
américa de franz a 24
gracias por la invitación a un saludo
especial a todos los televidentes de
france 24 en esta mañana julio se salvó
en un placer volverlo a saludar después
de tanto tiempo jaja quiero empezar por
no por un tema y es mucha gente se
pregunta por qué las petroleras con
tantas ganancias que tienen y con tanta
producción y países que son productores
porque los precios de la gasolina son
tan caros sabiendo que los países son
productores nosotros elaboramos un
gráfico con base en
con base en datos de la agencia
especializada bloomberg en la que en los
que demuestran que por ejemplo para una
persona en brasil llenar su tanque de 55
litros de gasolina equivale al 33 por
ciento de un salario mínimo mensual y
esa cifra depende de los países vamos a
ver el gráfico por ejemplo miren méxico
es el 24 por ciento del salario mínimo
en argentina 19 por ciento y así va
bajando en colombia es un 13% entonces
en general y con base en estos datos del
gráfico por cómo cada situación
bueno muchas gracias daniela un saludo
especial qué bueno volver a verte es
igualmente después de tanto tiempo
definitivamente estamos hablando de un
recurso natural no renovable
cuyo
explotación se agota en el tiempo y que
la función principal de cualquier
compañía petrolera llámese una compañía
privada o una compañía de carácter
nacional como las que tenemos
básicamente en latinoamérica petrobras
sector pedevesa con todas las
dificultades petroecuador petroperú es
maximizar las ganancias de la
explotación de estos recursos y
obviamente eso se logra vendiendo sus
productos en este caso el petróleo o los
combustibles que producen y refinan a su
costo oportunidad que es el costo
oportunidad es el precio al cual yo
puedo vender un producto en una economía
abierta y más tratándose de un bien
transable como los combustibles o como
el petróleo que está regido por unas
variables de oferta y demanda en el
mercado como tú lo decías en estos
momentos tenemos una coyuntura mundial
donde tenemos un déficit en la semana en
la oferta mundial de petróleo que está
generando que en una demanda que sigue
estable y sigue creciendo por efecto de
la reactivación económica post pandemia
haga que los precios estén en niveles
altos además después de estar
influenciadas por una coyuntura asociada
a variables externas como la guerra de
ucrania que tenemos en estos momentos
donde hoy cerca del 10 por ciento de la
producción mundial de petróleo está en
riesgo y eso hace que los precios estén
en niveles altos por encima no si el
dólar es por vales eso significa que las
petroleras maximizar sus ganancias
basado en esa oportunidad que tienen de
colocar en el mercado ahora muy
diferente ya es las decisiones que toman
los estados de a partir de esas
ganancias en el caso de empresas
petroleras nacionales como el caso de
copetrol o cerveza objetivo gas o
petroperú o petroecuador de subsidiar o
vender sus combustibles internos por
debajo de ese precio de oportunidad eso
ya es una decisión que toman los estados
pero definitivamente las petroleras
tienen la obligación de maximizar sus
ingresos ya que hace el estado con esas
ganancias y como los invierte los
distribuye y como le traslada de sus
beneficios a los consumidores finales de
los productos ya es una decisión de
política de estado que puede tomar
varias direcciones una dirección
sencilla puede ser simplemente mentir en
sus precios por debajo de ese precio de
oportunidad que en economía esto se
denomina un subsidio económico otra
decisión puede ser reducir los impuestos
que hoy se tienen a los combustibles
líquidos como recientemente anunciaba
eeuu que se está haciendo impuestos que
se establecen para reconocer el carácter
contaminante que tiene el uso de este
recurso natural no renovable que son los
combustibles líquidos y el deterioro que
genera son sobre la infraestructura de
los países en los que se vienen
contaminantes o una decisión adicional
es intervenir definitivamente a ambas
variables de tal forma que tengamos una
combinación de menores precios y
obviamente menores impuestos pero eso
significa definitivamente un impacto
fiscal porque significa dejar de recibir
unos recursos importantes y dejar de
invertir posiblemente esos recursos que
genera la explotación petrolera en otras
variables sino a tus bienes públicos que
podrían generar una mayor rentabilidad
social llámese verbigracia
infraestructura vial salud pública
educación que tanto demanda en nuestras
regiones pero ya son decisiones internas
de la política pública y es un error que
las petroleras no apoyen ese beneficio
que hoy tienen y esa posibilidad de
maximizar los ingresos como tal
claroscuro césar por lo que estudiante
entiendo que está hablando digamos es
una opción que tienen los estados más no
una obligación porque es que también
hemos visto muchísimas protestas en
nuestros países sobre todo las más
visibles digamos yo creo que hasta el
momento ha sido en las de panamá por
esta alza a las combustibles además
panamá un país es medianamente tranquilo
donde no pasa como mucha revuelta social
pues ya se nos dijo por favor que bajen
los precios de los combustibles en cómo
hacer digamos para que el estado
encuentre un equilibrio y el subsidio
pues realmente ya no se convierte en un
problema y no se convierta en un déficit
de fiscal julio
por supuesto depende mucho del escenario
de cada país esto hablar de panamá el
escenario panamá es mucho más crítico
porque panamá no produce hidrocarburos
no refinada aunque tiene digamos algunos
centros de abastecimiento muy
importantes y eso le permite ser un gran
trader o comercializador de cruz y
productos a nivel de la región pero
obviamente él tiene que importar la
totalidad de los combustibles que
demanda su economía y pues obviamente
eso lo hace a precio internacional por
supuesto la opción que tiene de vender
los precios en el mercado interno
implica sacar esos recursos de otras
variables o de otros sectores económicos
de que el país genere ingresos por
ejemplo panamá todo el tema de comercio
todo el tema de turismo y destinarlos a
cubrir el décimo déficit como tal que
significaría vender esos precios esos
combustibles por debajo de su costo
oportunidad y es una situación que es
similar en toda la región si bien es
cierto países como colombia ecuador perú
y brasil producimos y debo carburos
petróleo directamente y se dice en
muchos de ellos que somos
autosuficientes
la realidad es que no tenemos la
capacidad suficiente de refinar los
combustibles que mandamos entonces te
doy por ejemplo el caso de colombia
colombia así produce 740 mil barriles
por día de petróleo refinado cerca de
320 mil barriles por día pero está
demandando hoy más de 380 mil barriles
por día lo que significa que tiene que
importar una parte de sus combustibles a
un precio internacional muy superior y
tomar una decisión interna venderlo por
debajo de se puede es internacional eso
es una decisión de política pública y un
juego del día a día como tal julio césar
también yo le trasladó las preguntas que
me hacen a mí también diariamente y es
porque cuando el año pasado hace dos
años los precios del petróleo estuvieron
tan bajos inclusive en terreno negativo
porque no había demanda por el cob y 19
en ese momento los precios de la
gasolina no bajaron al mismo ritmo que
ahora están subiendo con con la subida
que en ese momento si nos ayudará a
recordar qué pasó en ese momento para
que los precios no cayeran tanto yo no
recuerdo un galón de gasolina menos de 5
mil pesos en colombia y hoy están 9 mil
pesos
daniela eso es muy importante
recordemos que los precios de los
combustibles tienen como tres
componentes básicos un componente que
remunera como tal el producto en sí que
es básicamente la combinación entre el
precio del petróleo y un margen de
refinación asociado a la actividad de
transformación o de producción del
combustible a partir del petróleo el
otro componente son los impuestos que en
general como te decía hace un rato son
una decisión que toman los países de
establecer un impuesto para penalizar un
bien que es contaminante y que genera
deterioro en la infraestructura que
nuestros países pueden estar en promedio
entre el 18 y el 30 por ciento como tal
y que generalmente sus impuestos no
dependen en sí del precio del energético
base es decir del petróleo más el margen
de respiración si no son un valor fijo
que se indexa anualmente por indicadores
económicos llámese principalmente
inflación o índice de precios al
consumidor como tal y el otro componente
son los márgenes asociados a la cadena
de distribución y comercialización donde
hablamos del transporte entre las
refinerías y los centros de
almacenamiento entre los almacenamientos
de servicio y pues obviamente están los
márgenes de los agentes que conforman la
cadena de distribución es decir que hay
cerca de un 40 por ciento de la
estructura que son costos fijos
asociados a impuestos y a márgenes de
comercialización como tal es decir
cuando bajan los precios internacionales
se da una bajada es en el 60% y
adicionalmente países como colombia para
el caso que tú señalas en el 2020 no
había alcanzado su precio internacional
estaba muy por debajo no tanto como
estamos hoy pero en ese momento tenía
cerca de 2 mil pesos por galón por
debajo del puesto internacional eso hizo
que al bajar los precios el precio se
equilibrará con el mercado internacional
y nos quedáramos básicamente en un
precio muy estable aunque si colombia
hizo una bajada en su momento de cerca
de 2 mil pesos en la gasolina y cerca de
mil pesos en él dice por supuesto para
la gente eso es mucho más entendible
cuando el precio sube menos predecible
cuando el precio baja y los precios que
se queja más cuando hay altas